I understand my life is fragile like
this the game I can't repeat the name is
what your head doesn't work and
everything will change
Zippity help them feel justice wanna be
a patient hella tricky good morning
world how are you hope everybody is
super duper well this is tee with Gary B
on a Monday June 29th big shout out to
Zeus mg on Twitch Ridge Porter what's
good
Tony Timur in the building Jerry Garcia
not be but Vicky Jaya good to see you on
Facebook
professor kevin wait to see to a hope on
facebook good to see Andre cut not on
the group on Facebook Dione Wu on
Twitter good to see you good to see
everybody everybody wears LinkedIn that
was like dinner comments on like there
we go has run Nazario holding it down
for LinkedIn Dustin what's good how are
you good good weekend yeah very good
weekend you buy any sports cards any
Pokemon I got one for free
nice what do your in Fox yeah big on
that summit be somebody's a fan of yours
and they send it to you yeah it was a
previous guest John Tory he said he said
he had a bunch and then he already made
his money back so he wanted to give me
one other Oh
so yeah that's right I mean kindness is
always a good move
Friday's sports card tea with Gary Vee
was fun like I really want to do like a
10-hour one let's do it hope everybody's
super did morning morning morning oh
yeah good to see you too we met when you
were in January I never come into your
office it was acquitted of you were fat
you did a fantastic job
oh thanks yeah good to see you this is
Angela she's my co-founder
what's happening this morning how
you all good it's really nice to see you
ladies yeah awesome no I just wanted to
jump into our question I know we have a
few minutes um so we're putting on the
women's social media days summit
tomorrow which is social media day June
30th and sometimes we get pushback from
businesses business owners you know
they're like you know social media is
not that effective or maybe like they
don't get as many conversions off of
social media so kind of you know
basically getting a lot of put not a lot
but sometimes we get pushback from from
from you know you get you get yo I say I
say a couple games one a lot of
businesses are right when they push back
against social because they are asking
the social media experts or companies
for short term sales conversion and the
social media people are actually not
hearing them and they're and they're and
they're talking about the
multidimensional aspect of social which
is it is definitely a communications you
know portal PR it is unbelievably a
brand to play like television the amount
of money that a lot of businesses spend
on social is so small and they're
looking for miracles from social that
doesn't come from print for Google and
then most people in social are not good
at selling you know one of the things
that I think makes vaynermedia strong
and what makes me strong with like
empathy or like k-swiss or you know
whatever is I really understand how to
do creative and media we understand how
to do creative in media my
organization's understand how to do
creative media to actually create short
term results many social media people
only take on community management and
some random organic content which has no
prayer to create short term short term
sales conversions which leads to the
mass cynicism of businesses you know we
are in the early stages of social these
first 10 years and you know what that
means is you have a lot of hucksters
that come on and try to ride the wave
and aren't actually good at servicing
you know clients and helping people grow
their business
make false promises and more importantly
don't even understand the question that
the business is asking them and so I
actually have a lot of empathy for a lot
of businesses that struggle with social
media because the person that's trying
to provide the results nine out of ten
times didn't hear it
or bullshitted their way to get the
money but had no chance of delivering
and I think you know I think that's the
real punchline to be honest but can you
create short-term results of course you
can that's why so many brands have been
built on Instagram and Facebook of
course you can but it actually takes
real talent I I can play basketball but
that doesn't mean I can play in the NBA
and I think right now we have a lot of
people selling social media that are not
ready for the NBA I am the other hand
and [ __ ] LeBron James so it's
definitely a more long-term plays really
and I think I think maybe that's a
misconception in like the marketplace is
that a lot of business owners think that
like hey social media like let's get it
done in Rome tomorrow I'm gonna be a
millionaire so I think well I mean
anytime anybody I mean that's why
because it's all right now at sports
cards I'm talking about it so much
yeah it's nothing is easy everything
takes education executions patience on
the flip side I don't you know I don't
want to make it I don't want to gloss
over this if somebody gave me $10,000
and said the number one thing I want
Gary is sales I
I know how to run ads on Facebook and
Instagram and YouTube pre-roll to make
that happen I might not have enough
money in that 10,000 to make content and
run media to create the sales that that
person they anticipates and so that's
why your femen upfront conversation but
most people just want to take on the
money
so really it's all about framing then
when you're having the conversation with
the client and asking questions right
set my expectations for real right now
you this is why so many people watching
right now whether they're watching live
on TV Gary Vee or when they watch this
clip on YouTube or Instagram
the reason they turn so many clients is
they just want the dollars but they only
get three months worth of dollars and
get fired the reason I've been able to
build something from zero to two hundred
million dollars in revenue is we keep
clients because we're not full of [ __ ]
upfront we really you know calibrate
what the request is and then we go
execute right I like that I like that so
I think that that's really important
Jean as we have our social media day
tomorrow is to really talk about the
frame right and setting that expectation
even for solopreneurs that do the social
media themselves let me give you another
example that may help a lot of people a
lot of people are paying $3,000 a month
for PR and then are paying 2,000 for
social media and not getting results
from social media they're mad at social
media meanwhile social media oftentimes
can outperform traditional PR every day
of the week but this agency or the
person or the internal person didn't
frame social as a PR comms thing they
framed it as a sales thing which again
it can easily be done 90% are not good
at the combination of media and creative
they're good at the creative part the
organic part the community management
part which services as PR or brand again
you have a lot of b2b businesses that
will buy a banner at a little league
stadium or or by a by a booth at a
convention that they don't convert but
they do it because they they have to do
it it's the cost of entry to be in the
industry cost of entry to be in the
industry of the world is to have a
social media account going hard LinkedIn
Facebook Twitter like any business that
isn't spending two to five thousand
dollars a month just to keep the lights
on I'm creative just for brand realizing
that people search I mean to me it's
more important than your website you
know people search to see what you're
doing there but people but most small
social media individuals and the
agencies and internal operators don't
position it as a comms branding cost of
entry in 2024 consumer respect and
conversion too many businesses are in
transactional mode sales mode we spent
2,000 how many sales that I get but they
didn't realize that one of the sales
they got that month was because somebody
went to their Instagram and Twitter and
saw that their real Wow sure but I mean
it's just so many times that clients
really expect like oh you know the sales
I need the sales I think they do need
the sales and by the way anybody who
wants to be
the monster like I did have to be
incredible at the ability to drive sales
through Facebook media and Instagram
media and LinkedIn media and Google
pre-roll YouTube content like it's very
rich tik toks real influencer marketing
is real it's real it's way harder than
putting out happy Flag Day on your
Twitter that's true and that goes by
entire Jimmy yeah it's all inclusive I
think I think that well that's why I'm
obsessed with it yeah it's the by now
it's the most we 60 thing in marketing
you know tbh yeah you know it's great
for brand but but YouTube and Facebook
videos can do brand and have a link
right there and create no friction for
the conversion of sale you know paying a
PR person $4,000 a month to get you
press when you can get pressed just by
posting so it's yeah it's the most
encompassing 360 way to do marketing
expectations thank you guys I wish you
well tomorrow yeah thank you so much
appreciate your time and yeah thanks so
much talk to you soon bye bye
no I kind of just want to rock my hair
like this today I've been up for about
an hour and a half big shout out to
Lorde in New Orleans thank you for that
favorite show shout out DJ yes Mina I
appreciate you me read what's good I
missed you too Ryan X Lexus K what's
good
I agree B Hicks I like this look all
right let's keep it going Jordan very
good not too much mate it's it's very
light here in Melbourne nearly 12 oh
yeah I said I sent you a leak ages ago
we never got to mean up in in Melbourne
Judas and bad weather but I'm wondering
if you ever watch that bold and bankrupt
video on the brusque your hometown I
don't I don't know can you can you make
sure Dustin gets the URL so I definitely
see it this weekend yeah yeah well thank
you so much um so my question for you
where it's been variance in here in
Australia due to covert obviously our
government has
basically given a few businesses and
we've been one of those that is quite
lucky that essentially we've been giving
a cash flow boost of equivalent of a
month's worth of sales stack pattern a
stimulus check essentially makes sense
yeah and look I think that the thing
that I find most interesting about you
is that it's not just your ability to
understand attention but to allocate
capital I make you feel there's a
vertical company you've got media assets
creative the media side of the
businesses well production I guess I'm
curious from your side for you as a
younger entrepreneur when you first had
a veiner in vaynermedia what were the
smartest investments was it in people or
was you literally took the words out of
my mouth it was in David Zhang it was in
Marcos Chris astok lives in Joe
Whitmarsh Phil Toronto it was in humans
not cinema it was it was humans you know
Kevin McCarthy and Tina C and it was
there's just nothing close to the humans
it was the humans yeah and now that but
you understand that's cuz I like
managing people and I like people so the
answer to you know the answer is not for
everybody some people are quite
introverted and awkward and don't enjoy
the process of humans and for them the
answer would have been technology you
know for a lot of different companies
the answer was we hired four engineers
we barely talked to each other remotely
we built this awesome product and that
started it for me my great strengths is
the enjoyment of people the
understanding of people the compassion
for people even when people are mean and
angry and judgmental of me even then I
don't get triggered and I have you know
a beautiful I'm so grateful for my I
mean I'm just so I mean I kiss my
parents on the face for this I'm I you
know my sir I kiss my immigrant
circumstances and the face for this my
genuine genuine love for people I mean
right now we're going through a time in
the world where you know in the US and
and many other places enormous fractions
miiverse you you versus them and and to
me my great strength is finding that
common ground of compassion empathy
genuinely caring about your fellow
and trying to act on it
which is always very very challenging
through a business world because your
business realities as well but for me
you as people so yes and so we're we're
in this early stage now obviously
running an agency we've got probably
five or six staff and I guess I was
curious I tried to jump back three four
years ago to some of your videos around
your first hires who were the family and
friends family implants mm-hmm I'm a big
family and friends died why because it's
different if you because it's it's
stickier do you know it's a trust thing
yeah of course even if they're not
experienced yeah of course yeah yeah
yeah of course it's family because we're
having that right now we're we're hiring
for different roles that we haven't
hired for in the past and I I love you
you know there was let me jump in I
apologize one of the things that I had
was I knew the role yeah when I was
hiring these kids my brother's friends
from college and high school or hardcore
fans of why my btv that I knew for five
or six years of mine when I was hiring
for them
the big key was I knew how to do all
those jobs thus I could judge if they
were progressing if you don't know the
jobs you're more of a pickle in that
scenario yeah well I mean I've been
doing pretty much everything strategy
sales and marketing before for about
three years two years maybe three years
and my co-founder does all creative
production and I don't have an industry
background so it's been very interesting
me neither
yeah you don't have to had the
experience you just have to know that
yeah I will the hardest thing is like
you said is I was deliberating and
speaking to another owner probably the
biggest independent agency and he was
like you really need to be particular
about the role it is that you're hiring
because people are just not they're not
you they're not going to have the same
same passion and be able to do all the
things and they shouldn't and they
shouldn't and owners and bosses and CEOs
should not hold their employees
accountable to that same level of
with ours because they're not being
compensated the same way he believes
that the greatest well the first hire
that he should always go to if he was to
pick account manager strategist then
creative the first should always be
account manager because they'll pay for
the other two from I understand that and
I see a lot of validity that I think the
first hire is the single person that
reverse engineer is the founder CEO
leader so for me that was an admin yeah
do you know because because that was my
weakest length of like not wanting to do
that kind of work so I think you hire a
rat and by the way if you know I don't
know who what that gentleman did for a
living if he was a creative or
what-have-you but if you yourself are an
account person potentially the first
hire that matters is a creative yeah
well I pulled the pit there the wisest
decision was a strategist because I
don't you know i'm not a marketer per se
and i come from that account management
sales background but a sales person
matters I've seen I've seen shops that
start with five people that can do
something but not one of them can sell a
[ __ ] ice cream in a desert and they
go out of business I think it's I think
these are all self-awareness games for
all of us out here yeah do you if you
think back to that time in those first
days how long until you realistically
realize you could stop working in that
real nitty-gritty of day-to-day where
you're just constantly involved in I'm
still a management yeah but like you
know what I mean when you're you're
literally the Account Manager the
salesperson the market soon as soon as
you can afford it yeah you know that was
about two years for us yeah it's
exciting though yeah there's nothing
more fun than building Jordan thank you
so much brother I wish you well too make
sure I check out that video
Chiz thank you here's some thoughtful
shits and thoughtful business [ __ ] here
to start the real like operations a
little bit more people that have started
a business a little bit then
entrepreneurship I like that little nice
twist let's keep it going oh my god hi
Gary hi Miriam how are you I'm good how
are you
I'm sorry iconic
crisis this is real right now thanks
where are you from I'm from Australia I
live in Adelaide so I'm one stay over
well
oh thank goodness because some people
really hate my city and they make fun of
it a lot
I don't know apparently there's nothing
to do here um you know it is rubbish
they're serious wine and a delay so I
know dairy weed okay
Adelaide has won the Australia game
thank you so much for that I'm sorry
Wow I can't really nervous so first of
all I just want to say thank you this
show has become a massive part of my
life over the last few months pretty
much since it started so I'm a digital
artist
and pretty much since it started I've
just been like making drawings based on
things that you say throughout the
episodes and I've been like posting them
on social media and it's just like
honestly bought in some of the best
people I've interacted with you know and
it's just taught me a lot about what I'm
capable of and the type of you know
content creation and things like that so
I just want to say thank you because you
know without covert or lockdown we
wouldn't have this show and yeah I
wouldn't you know be on that right so um
so my question uh could I just give a
little bit of context to it that's sorry
um so I have endometriosis I don't know
if you know that elinoz okay so um so
this year has been a little bit rocky
for me I basically dropped out of
university because I had a bunch of
health issues come up and I had to have
a surgery and I was pretty much failing
all my classes and I just it was just
really hard to kind of do the whole
thing and do my you know universities
doctor shop and no it's the case but
what's ironic is through all of that all
of the AA and the t you know all of this
has been one of the biggest things that
has helped me to be honest but at the
moment I'm in this really weird
situation where I don't know
whether I should go back to university
or if I take a break and I know that you
know I know your opinions on on college
and that I must take the platform like
my opinions are college works for some
it just doesn't work for a lot more
people than the world has accepted yes
especially people that take on debt and
get a degree that gives them no ROI the
second they walk out of school like that
is incredibly scary to me that's a very
big us problem obviously other parts of
the world have education paid for in
different ways what I also think but I
also think it's about happiness I mean
like I always think about why like why
do you go to college do you go to
college to people like well Gary it's
not just about the degree it's about the
social growth I'm like well you can go
backpacking through Europe so yeah you
know like you don't you know you could
be around young people and not pay for
the education part you know the reason I
assert I feel like my attitude towards
that has changed over the last couple of
years I'm actually draw I've dropped out
twice so I dropped out in my second year
I took the whole year off for
endometriosis that was the year I was
diagnosed and that year was the year I
basically taught myself digital arts so
I I kind of went like completely
opposite direction and now I have this
thing that I absolutely love and I do it
every single day and I try to put myself
out there on social media and everything
like that but I feel like I'm kind of my
head is always in true directions like I
have this creative side and then I have
this academic side but what comes with
the academic side is like the literal
pain I experienced just think about that
just I know I rewatched this like like
like even if it was 1975 when colleges
are a why was extraordinarily strong you
could get a job immediately and you
couldn't get one without it and it paid
for itself based on the cost of the
degree even then if it's literally
brought you pain the answer is it's not
it's not a good idea you know I mean I
think you know at some point here people
are gonna realize happiness over money
like yeah at some point it's gonna
happen
I just believe it and flip the world
upside down and I think a lot of the
things I debate and think about will
come into focus during that time yeah I
was gonna say so this is one of the
biggest reasons I started listening to
you you're honestly I'm so sorry I'm
really nervous at the moment I've I'm so
excited to be here but I just um your
your content honestly changed my life
because I feel like I've I tend to judge
myself a lot unnecessarily
I really don't need to be like that and
I find it really hard to snap out of
that sometimes and I just honestly turn
you on and listen to like I listening to
your content day in day out creating
stuff based on your content is one of
like I've said it before but honestly
it's just one of the like most positive
things that I've done with my time and
sorry I was just gonna say I think no no
I I want my I'm wildly clatter to keep
going I just wanted to talk like I know
you talk a lot about like you know when
you do or don't do something you don't
judge yourself for it and I just won
your perspective because like I tend to
tie my self-esteem up in a lot of these
things and like what is your advice for
like letting go of that completely by
focusing on realizing like it's almost
by muting the accolades more yeah the
negativity I think what's really worked
for me
is the humility leads to the ability to
not have your self-esteem wrapped up and
the win or the loss to me it was about
when things were working for me not
thinking that I was special or better
than anybody
yeah it was it was actually in the
humility that I found peace no I don't I
don't come off as a humble person
because I like because I talk loud I'm
aggressive I'm competitive I like sports
I like competition
but in in my in my real kind of core I
don't think I'm special in any shape or
form I really genuinely don't I
genuinely genuinely do not yeah and and
because of that when people said you're
a genius oh you saved my life or or all
these things you're the goat it's it
feels amazing I'm so grateful it's so
nice however however I don't take it to
heart
I don't begin to believe it and so what
that also means is when somebody says
you're full of [ __ ] you suck you're the
worst it allows me to not get torn down
and so I just kind of stay in the middle
like to me I think a lot about being a
hundred years old and do I care about
what-what an anonymous person or even my
cousin thought of me at a hundred
brett75 or being terminally diagnosed I
mean you've already had a health scare
you know you know you can really use
this I think you have to think back to
the judgment you had growing up that
doesn't mean demonize your parents or
circumstance it means just understand it
because they probably have the same
thing happening to them and and really
just reframing so I talked about
positivity and practicality in two more
years the reason you're in a better
place is you've been listening to a lot
of what I'm saying which I'm grateful
and it sounds like it's bringing you
some value I mean ultimately when you
realize you don't matter that much it is
actually liberating yeah I agree
yeah that's how I do it that's man but
I'm at and realizing what's important to
me like who cares if my business failed
or my post and do well or people think
I'm a bad guy like my parents are
healthy that as long as that simply just
keep it simple and humble keep it simple
keep it home laughs keep it simple keep
it humble and you will watch your
happiness explodes
that doesn't mean stay complacent I'm
the [ __ ] most hungry ambitious person
you'll meet but I really really just
keep it simple and humble yeah yeah
that's awesome thank you so much Gary
you're cool I'm so sorry kid you follow
me on Instagram because I make a lot of
artwork and it's actually wait you
shared some of it I'm so sorry Gary my
mind
completely blanked this I wasn't
following I'm on it now okay it's
absolutely fine no no but yeah I I just
uh
yeah those those building drawings were
based on the how to build the tallest
building and it's just does you know
you're at you're at 519 let's see what
the vaynernation does for you over the
next hour I thought I just want to say
thank you so much Gary
this means yeah thank you so much you're
welcome everybody follow this wonderful
ladies all right let's keep it rockin
mondo how are you you're on mute good
man how's it going it's going well
really nice good Gary I said my name is
Max I'm at least twenty sixteen I'll
quickly kind of run through and first
off thanks for all the content you do it
was about twenty sixteen I put together
what is essentially a neon business it's
neon signs in fact we actually did the
puts the the twitch studio with your
signature in green yes yes thank you yes
I actually walked it in your office into
this [ __ ] and the shipping Depot and
actually dropped it on Ted I don't know
Gary won't let me up actually so
actually how it got up there it was kind
of fun taking on a subway and driving
down there those are kind of kind of the
fun hustle think the kid thinks put
through but basically I wanted to make
something that I kind of knew enough
about the business and it's kind of
those tricky businesses it's a little
sticky it's a hundred years old
hasn't changed at all but it has a lot
of creativity and a lot of value kind of
in the sense that people are actually
working in these fires you know and so
what I did is I just created it like
kind of like a media side to all of it
it kind of what would essentially have
minions it became almost like a used car
salesman approach you know I've got some
signs I can get it up there for you you
know I just felt like the template was
so old and so I tried to bring in this
other idea you know kind of artistic
side the creative side so my question is
that I 15 years may in new york city
have now moved to Louisville Kentucky
and the operation is really still just
me kind of running everything the media
every putting everything out we have a
podcast the only podcast about neon
signs and that kind of keeps you over 80
episodes now basically putting other
artists on other shops that actually had
no boy
kind of limited to that they're only
doing you know kind of like they're in
no little town but now they've Instagram
that's all kind of shifted which is
great you know they all kind of know
each other now and there's this larger
landscape so I'm trying to figure out
what are the best ways to you know
basically being you know connected and
Cove it's kind of limiting and all that
what would you do you know transitioning
from you know a place like a place like
New York City where everything's kind of
quickly happening a lot of businesses
and everything everyone's kind of
transitioning them what is essential to
them so it's kind of been a slow down I
think naturally because these things you
know kind of do come up sometimes you
know what what to spend on as far as
businesses but it was consumer direct
consumer I shipped the neon signs so it
shipped throughout the nation so you
know a lot of business in LA a lot of
things in New York that we used to do
how can you you know what would be some
of the things we do to transition to
like the Midwest well I mean are you
unable to ship the neon signs to New
York in LA no they can go anywhere
anywhere in the nation to ship me so
what's like workers so what's the
concern you you mean more of some of the
local low-hanging fruit in New York is
stronger than in Louisville okay they're
just wrapping something off in my office
not necessarily that but you think what
did some of that like I think trying to
get the word out that you know we're
also here now you know done such a good
job of putting out information in New
York I mean I think and have you
separated that from the fact that neon
signs becomes one of the line items that
disappears storing an economic turndown
I think that some of it - like how do
how to adjust definitely is you know I
think I think during these times you
just have to quote-unquote weather -
storm like everything you were doing to
get a certain amount of sign sold you
almost have to do twice as much just to
keep you know it's kind of what I did
both downturns at the wine business
right it took so much more effort in in
April 2000 because the stock market
crash and then September 2001 because of
9/11 it took me so much effort in 2000
2001 2002 to basically be even at the
level of 1999 even though we were
growing because it was taught than 2000
they'd forget it I mean one of the first
things that disappeared was $60 wine and
so I think you have to realize that 100%
reality around it's going to take you
more at
more podcast episodes more Facebook
Louisville local advertising because now
and when you get in front of 200 people
in Louisville you know a year ago 13 of
them would have bought a sign now only 3
well because of the financial situation
and the needs I think during these times
I mean I think nothing's changed max
unlike what platforms can work whether
that's tick-tock or LinkedIn or YouTube
what's changed is the conversion
behavior you know it's and I think it's
kind of like I think about it I think
about is gaining weight if you like
during kovat gained 15 pounds when you
go back to the gym nothing's changed you
can do the same regimen that was gotten
into that shape the problem is it's
gonna take longer to get back to a great
place cuz you put on the 15 pounds and
you've got a unitard or you're out of
practice your joints or a little [ __ ]
up you know like you know you're you
what you see you know sometimes when I
miss some gym time is a damn you know
October did like just last August to
like October of December was probably
the weakest time frame of my workout in
the last five years and and it was
really tough to get back to the same
place and I think that's what people
gonna deal with within the post kovat
and so more reps is what you're saying
basically just eight more reps and
recognizing that those reps are not
gonna give you the same returns that
they once did but you've got to get
through otherwise I mean people like
Kerry that sucks I'm like cool what's
the alternative going out of business
yeah and his cool thing it's also like
for the one we did a sign for empathy
that was up there too yes we just didn't
want for tracer and Jonathan so that
just when I thought it would be so he's
got that over there now it's actually at
his house so I'll be fun hopefully he
gets to open up and guys good to see you
back at the office so I think the little
things like that yeah and so I think I
think local Facebook and LinkedIn
advertising in the area of Lexington
will bring you more dividends than you
realize so I would really focus on that
okay thanks good awesome better tuck you
soon thanks for all the nice gestures
you've done for being your ex thank you
let's push I like this show thought ball
hey how's it going Gary very good man
very excited to be here anyway so huge
shout out your team Zayn Dustin you guys
Rock thank you so much hey that guy's
Zubin is a beast by the way I'm loving
that content I'm a business owner I run
a business everything that guy says
since we really really well thought out
so looking for that today Manor Commerce
is very strong and he's very sharp love
it love it anyways so want to tell you
you'll get a kick out of this I am you
know me I'm that guy
used to be in corporate making 100k plus
I left that life it just you know it
wasn't for me won't happen I'm I came to
Mexico that's where I am right now it's
where I'm based learnt from start at a
call center I just focused on helping
people that run Facebook Ads
follow up with their leads so we kind of
come in and work we're part of an
ecosystem that helps people convert
their leads into life transfers into
appointments all that kind of stuff
right we hire kids that are here grew up
in the u.s. came back to Mexico that in
every sense of the word their American
Gary but you know we kind of help them
out we get in this job and they're
working for companies in the US like
digital marketing agencies real estate
agents we're focused on real estate
that's our niche that's our area so my
question to you is this Gary so given
that you know and we've grown the
company I have 50 people working for me
right now we have over yeah thank you
and we have over 300 clients across the
u.s. and Canada so and we weathered the
kovat right I mean we survived we're
here and the number one thing I did was
in the middle of March when it got real
I started going live on Facebook I
finally followed a lot of your advice I
had been not wanting to post anything I
didn't really want to be in the face of
the company well I stopped in the middle
March right so you know we went down a
little bit but man we survived to Cove
it and I think we're ready to thrive
right now my concern is this Gary as the
leader of the company I'm like okay
should we double down on real estate or
is it trying to open up
other niches because holy cow what's
that both both what do you mean double
down on real estate and expand when
people expand they oftentimes forget the
thing that got them there so if you have
a hundred beans to deploy going forward
make 70 of those beans go on real estate
cuz it's working and you haven't
extracted all that value yet and then
take 30% and go into flooring or
insurance or small business whatever
whatever you think is right so the
internet both both and and and Gary for
when you're running an organization like
that how do you keep them I mean the
focus right cuz right now one of our
biggest you know strengths and you know
selling points says hey we know real
estate for a hundred percent real estate
this is our thing this is what we do how
do you can't change what you say to
people kind of Istanbul you ready you
need to work with us now I know you're
in the hardware store business we rush
real estate that's our origins but we've
taken those nuances and we understand
the hardware space and we think the
comps are there and then when you talk
to Gustavo the real estate guy or gal
you say hey Gustavo look art you need to
go with us in real estate
that's our origins the first three years
of my company it's still 90% of our
behavior we've expanded into insurance
and mutual funds and Wall Street but we
are realistic all of a sudden just by
delivering it differently you're in both
I got you in the day and kind of you
know play that real estate DNA but how
it applies to how that like you said the
nuances can apply that much which is
true 100% true by the way I mean a lot
of that always vegetables yeah I know
it's [ __ ] true hundred percent yeah
no that's really good advice Gary and on
the social when I'm putting my content
out there I'm working in a call center
Gary and well I've moved the whole
company virtual now what does really
awesome content look like if you're you
know neon sign guy I hundred-person
think well you know that's you and I
really freak on QA see what Gary me look
I got [ __ ] up here backlighting nobody
gives a [ __ ] about the production
everybody gives a [ __ ] about the
substance
I gotta get get great clients great
partners great people out here that that
they're looking at and to learn from
actually we have a lot of the same
bodies yeah or or just or just post on
LinkedIn or Facebook like who's got
questions I mean I'm not your [ __ ]
Gustavo in Mexico right now you're not a
great client or a big dog I'm here to
bring value bring [ __ ] value watch
what happens okay I guess awesome time
love it
thank you so much getting keep learning
it look it's the same old thing for me
Thank You Saba go ahead doesn't go
naturally I'm just wrapping up with a
thought um
it's similar you know I always talk
about like watch what I do not what I
say like a lot of the answers are in the
[ __ ] way I'm just limited thank you I
be thank you for that kind host Donny
what's good Gary what's up man
thanks Ron how are you done of course me
where you from where are you Pittsburgh
I'm in my car cause my roommates
sleeping tell your roommate to wake the
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] 9:30 knives I think
he actually is getting up now he's
getting ready to go work so for
marketing yourself as a voice actor as a
voice actor voice actor actor um I think
one of the things I would definitely do
is look at the number one animated
YouTube and Instagram and tick tock
animated pieces of content and try to be
the voice of something cuz you'll get a
huge amount of exposure no I I'm a
pretty big fan of you know with
vaynermedia and with speaking with Gary
Vee let's call it I did a lot of things
free early on to get exposure leverage
so I don't have to do right now but be
smart you have to give away three where
it's actually valuable to you what I
mean by that is you need to reach out to
things like Jim shark and like moon
juice like the biggest companies on
social media and say hey instead of like
a lot of times when people go for free
the reason a lot of people hate free is
they give free non strategically and
they just do it for whoever asks but
that but like you're not really getting
the experience
free you're getting exposure or
learnings in return yes I'm a very big
fan of doing voiceover you know podcasts
are exploding there's a ton of podcast
ads if you could become if you could
become a voice for like four to five big
companies that are running head I would
go to Spotify I would down literally I'm
not joking I would download all 300 top
podcasts on YouTube and Spotify sit down
for a week
listen to them all figure out figure out
which companies are advertising the most
on podcast and then cold reach out to
them and then offer it you know for
quote-unquote three take a you're gonna
get massive exposure and all of a sudden
you're like a voice that we're all
recognizing kind of like movie phone or
the guy who's like dark place you know
the trailers yeah I kind of specialize
in like character places like really
weird so so the so the animation idea
sits with you well yeah when we first
started quarantine
I started making Facebook Instagram I
started three months she got me up like
seven thousand my facebook Instagram I
know where I gotta figure out how to I
think your channel your chalk your
chopping for me a little bit but I would
tell you that then there's some feedback
going on yeah that's good can you hear
me is any closed tomorrow
it's pretty um yeah a little bit better
still chopping feedback can you go on
mute
can you put yourself um you um so I
think the thing that you need to think
about is LinkedIn and the thing that you
need to think about yeah doesn't let's
let's rock him off because I've got my
answer anyway
Donnie thank you for listening hey you
watch this cuz people in the comments
we're talking about hiring you and be
it's just exposure it's an exposure game
I do think LinkedIn is a good place to
go as well talk about your voice actor
and what that means for content on on
social and on on the ability to really
create the be the voice of their
pre-roll you too bad I think it's a real
shot and here's Donnie's information if
anybody wants to jam with him I don't
know if that's zero for over there's a
no or zero but you'll figure that out
alright to keep going Gary V what's up
Gary what's good Robbie hey um so I just
had a few quick couple questions I want
to ask you first of all I love your show
by the way I don't want you to persuade
yourself thank you thank you where are
you from Texas Dallas Texas yeah so so
what I wanted to ask you was you talked
a lot about self-awareness and like
becoming an entrepreneur and stuff and
when I was a kid I noticed I had a lot
of those tendencies but I kind of bought
into the whole you need to be good at
school in order to do well so I just
like went ham like 14 18 hours a day
into it and it was it was a mistake so I
was like the press unhappy so my
question is what like I know you talked
like look back when you were a kid to
see what you're doing but what if you've
just like struggled with depression all
this time so you weren't really doing
anything you know what I mean yeah of
course that makes sense which is why all
the stuff I talk about our hypotheses
and ideas but they don't always fit for
everybody depending on it so what you're
referring to for everybody's watching is
a lot of times people at 20 21 22 even
30 40 are asking me Gary I don't know my
passion I always ask them well what do
you do as a kid or what do you like but
sometimes you don't have to go as far as
what you did as a kid it might be Robbie
what you're doing right now like
I'm a big fan of paying attention to
what people consume like for example
I've been so busy with the all-in
challenge trying to keep the companies
along just a lot of [ __ ] black labs I
understand so much right in the few
minutes that I've had to myself I've
either look up sports cards and bought
them on eBay or have watched wrestling
documentaries on WWE that's a clear
indication of Who I am right now even of
what I like and thanks that begs the
debate that if I started a podcast
around wrestling sports wrestling cards
which oh by the way I genuinely believe
our underpriced and like have a big
opportunity that would make me
incredibly happy now I'm I'm wildly
happy doing what I'm doing so I won't
make that pivot yet but I always do
wonder if I'll ever have a breaking
point and all the pressure that I have
to hold and and am i okay with selling
it off or walking away and just doing
something simplistic like garage saling
or sports cars or things that nature I
would really look at what you gravitate
towards doing like what what do you
watch what do you do like what do you
like you know like what is it I would
say music sports video games cooking
travel skiing you know video games and
prime fiction writing and also I've been
reading a lot about entrepreneurship too
but I know you got to actually get out
there and do it well you got you got a
fiction right and you got to play video
games or record it so there's nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong with
educating yourself or consuming the push
I give when I'm like well you got to do
is that's the truth like you can't you
know nothing will happen by watching my
videos unlimited like you have to do
that thing there's nothing wrong with
consuming it's just that if you use
consuming as the justification that
you're doing you tend to get unhappy
right but I mean I mean Robbie I mean
you're in a place where you can start
YouTube videos and Instagram accounts
and tick tocks around video games and
fiction writing you can literally write
the first page of a fiction story that
you have in your mind in the Notes app
on your phone and post that on Instagram
with 12 followers and that could be the
moment it's unlikely but it could bright
that's true you got him you know what I
mean yeah
to your interests its leads to happiness
you're too young to give up on happiness
you know people that are 75 I'm willing
to say you can give up unhappiness and
what I mean by that is not giving up
unhappiness
I mean professional happiness I would
say okay you're 75 [ __ ] you're yes
you're allowed to go to save your money
or whatever just but hopefully you seek
some money if you want to go to Florida
or Arizona and just golf like cool but
if you're 52 right now and you hate your
[ __ ] job I don't want you to keep
doing that because there's another 20
years likely of you working based on
what I'm seeing in the numbers these
like like [ __ ] it's already like this is
why I don't want people buy houses that
are too expensive for them I don't want
people not to buy houses I don't want
people to buy houses that they can't
afford I don't want people to buy not
buy cars I don't want them buy cars they
can't afford I don't want people not buy
jewelry I don't want them to buy jewelry
that they can't afford I'm buying
[ __ ] hundreds of thousand dollars of
sports cards but I can afford it nobody
like that's stupid if you can't afford
it I want people to drink six dollar
coffees if they can afford it I don't
want them to buy it when they can't
saving money is incredibly important
living within your means is incredibly
important and more importantly having a
job you hate or doing something you hate
just to pay for stuff to make pretend
you were happy that's the worst of them
all right you've already lived that you
[ __ ] thought you had to do something
it made you unhappy and it became a
spiral and you became very unhappy I'm
25 right that's like 150 so you're super
young grow please promise me Robin do
you understand how young you are at 25 I
was thought I was stocking bottles on
shelves in a liquor store on this exact
moment for real checking in orders a
hundred percent at 25 years old 100
percent at this exact moment when I was
25 deliveries would come to shoppers
discount the course I think I'd be able
to wine library buy that wine library
deliveries would come 10 cases of doors
scotch five cases of Budweiser 13 cases
of a Sauvignon Blanc I bought and I
would [ __ ] check in the invoice okay
we got 13 check I would sign the invoice
I would then send it to the walk get out
hand truck ship it down a conveyor belt
take one case of the 15 Sauvignon Blanc
put it on the shelf get a piece like a
little card that I had write the review
of the Sauvignon Blanc put it up
customer walked in where's the Scotch
right over here ma'am right I'm like
like I was my life at 25 I was a [ __ ]
slepping in a liquor store that's true
okay okay that's what I was doing a 25
yeah I'm at a time so if you were to cuz
I know you worked in a liquor store and
that's actually the second part I wanted
to ask you about was what the work ethic
part I'm really I have a lot of
experience with that but where I don't
have experience is I grew up kind of
middle-class so that kind of like
lower-class hustle you always talk about
so to speak like I said I just graduate
for positon listen a lot of things I say
people take his blanket i I see writings
but but I have highly wealthy friends
that grew up rich on the Upper East Side
with unlimited grind and work ethic okay
I think your work ethic will explode
when you're doing something you love for
example I have the greatest great work
ethic but I don't see up to two o'clock
in the morning working on empathy the
case with steel the you know vaynermedia
but I stayed up to two o'clock in the
morning buying sports cards the other
night because my passion is off the
[ __ ] charts okay I think a lot of I
think most people are not lazy I think
they're doing something they don't like
I'm unbelievably lazy in school I'm
unbelievably lazy if you asked me to
hang six pictures up in an apartment
I can I can work for 18 hours straight
when I love it work ethic oftentimes
maps to the thing I think too many
people deem themselves as not ambitious
and lazy when in reality it's because
they don't like what they're doing right
right so would you if you just got a job
or I just graduated from college with
license and speech-language pathology I
do want it
no-no-no so initial awesome
so my question but would you in order to
make money to kind of support yourself I
mean that I'm kind of like thank you
Farah there's two ways I think about it
one and obviously let's take Cove it out
of the equation a year from now
hopefully so you know I mean obviously
those are some variables you want it you
live really humbly a K at your parents
house at a girlfriend's house you know I
don't know what your situation is or
what six homeys in a [ __ ] yeah then
it allows you to go real ham if you're
[ __ ] caught if you're paying $100 a
month in rent because you have six other
roommates and you sleep on a couch it
all depends on where you're at you know
you can get a speech pathology job and
then my concern with that is is that you
then live a lifestyle based on that
salary which never lets you really save
and go on to the other thing you could
get a speech pathology job and live like
[ __ ] so you save like a [ __ ] and you
could save for two years worth of living
and then you go and jump at 28 I'm a
little bit more into the happiness even
those three you're saving kind of suck
even when you have this great mission
but it's but there's a million different
examples I mean there's 25 year-olds
they have two children and have
responsibilities and like can't live in
a [ __ ] because they're scared for
their children there's a million
scenarios out there but for you like
where do you live no debt I'm in Dallas
right now I have like I have no debt or
anything my parents to care so I'm just
thinking should I just like pack up
somewhere and like become a bartender
you should definitely first of all you
should kiss your parents on the face and
thank them because no debts on Monster
absolutely I think you should start
creating on the internet to get a taste
if there's anything you like if your
entrepreneurial tendencies were around
flipping and selling like buying and
selling stuff you should give that
thought if it was more about like macro
entrepreneurship because there's a
difference between operations of
entrepreneurship sales entrepreneurship
sales entrepreneurship is an incredible
treat because it always lets you breathe
cassettes you breathe you know so I
think that's what you have to think
about ok ok not as much fun the idea
kind of wanting to go my own way side
versus more the strict selling besides
selling is one the skill
like I'd work kind of to build up I mean
there's also partnerships you have any
really good friends who like you know
you might want to team up but that's
always a fun thing to think about
look if I said to you right now you have
to start a business you have to it's
like the rule new mandated law what
would you do it probably try to become a
writer that's where my talent is so
maybe I don't do that bro you have to
start writing do right you're right like
do you put out your writing in the world
no I don't I need to think of a way to
do I've heard like what Pat and stuff
like but beyond that I don't really want
ads incredible Wattpad for everybody w
ATT pad um but I also think instagrams
incredible I think writing stuff on like
a set of notes and just posting it I
think then taking that and making a
youtube video where you read the story
you know you know you fiction write
fiction actually yeah listen to me and
listen to me good you need to seriously
consider just writing the first 10 pages
of a make content story putting them out
on Instagram reading them on YouTube
putting them out on tick-tock I would do
that for a year and see if anything
clicked you might have the next Harry
Potter [ __ ] Star Wars in you but you
don't even know but by putting it out
there you might see people jump on it
start you know reddit has some great
communities where you can start a
make-pretend land bro you got a go
Robbie you got it you got it you got to
eliminate the insecurities of feedback
like remember I think it's great and
then everybody else that says it sucks
tell them to DM me and I'll come to go
[ __ ] themselves you know what I mean you
got to put it out I've been really
indecisive and negative Gary but you've
helped it a lot thank you
wouldn't you say Ron oh I've been really
indecisive and negative for a lot of
time but you've helped that a lot so
thank you
I appreciate that why do you think that
because I want to learn from your
feedback because I want to do more of it
cuz it's the greatest feeling to bring
that kind of value to somebody like what
what clicked for you doing I would say
growing up making like nothing but a
even though a lot of people like what my
disabilities told me I would make like
C's DS fail stuff like that it was a lot
of nowadays
like dyslexia like common like like
Shady their ADHD auditory processing
slow process and speed all that sort of
an amalgamation of things with
depression so yeah and did that make you
feel inferior
it made me attached my I attached my
self-worth to praise so like aids Awards
because that was all I ever have an
audience in during was show you were you
were showing them you showed that see I
can't write as I had the ambition and
that was the direction I was sort of
given to go and what did your parents
think of that um I think they're
starting to realize more and more that
school never was for me my mom's the
very type a accountant like go make a
stuff like yeah I understand
listen so anyway I apologize so what
what do you think really clicked for you
uh with your videos mm-hmm just your
your very positive nature you can go out
do anything just tell people you're just
very frank that you have to look for you
in a lot of ways there's a way that came
across is genuine yeah and it's what I
don't think people understand is when
you go to that level of selfishness
there's an incredible ability to become
selfless me making myself happy well
over this whole process now allows me to
be the man that I am that sits here for
an hour every morning desperately
wanting for you to be happy with no
interest or expectation for anything in
return because it comes out of gratitude
that I've navigated to this place and I
want it for everybody else and if I'd
not done that I would be meaning not
giving had I not gone that route and and
and thought that I needed everybody
else's affirmation to live I'd still be
grabbing for that right now and I'd have
no opportunity to give it's the person
that's the happiest thing is able to
give you know it's the same reason that
all the trolling and negativity online I
feel bad for those people because
they're in a bad place yeah of course
you can't be compassionate or nice
you're not happy
that's what is that absolutely the
communication style in the format it
just kind of there was a practicality to
the way that I was describing it that
felt real to you yeah and also your
resume with school isn't the only way
and I always felt out of place in school
you know that's where I spell my time
because I just thought well that's the
way you do things and yeah well listen I
wish you nothing but good Robbie please
do me a favor please
I have a weird feeling about this and
really I'm probably just being selfish
right now because when you're on [ __ ]
Colbert talking about your book you're
gonna be like big very big
I really I really think you should write
three to five pages how many different
stories do you think you have in your
head really good ones maybe three how
many solid ones about three or five how
many okay one's about ten I want you to
put out all ten ten pages of each on the
internet for free and watch your [ __ ]
life change here I'm giving you the
straight formula I rarely do this as you
know I talk more I need you to write the
first 10 pages of each of those stories
all ten not three when you use the high
of this moment I don't need you to go to
actually the only one's good no no all
ten because what you think is just okay
might be the [ __ ] one but first you
don't get decide they get to decide got
it I want you to write the first 10
pages for all 10 I assume in the way
that it fits in an Instagram post that's
probably 20 to 5 posts per story to get
to 10 pages worth I don't really know
the math and this write 30 posts will 15
post you know what I mean right like
literally you know like part and don't
do a carousel this way you can do like 4
posts a day one of 10 it was an early
Wednesday morning
like literally name it and I want you to
do that then I want you to read it on
YouTube just like this face the camera
read it
that's your YouTube content and then I
want you to figure out some sort of
version of one of the two on tick-tock I
want you posting on all 3 of those and
add Twitter to that and do the same
thing you're doing on Instagram I want
you do that every day for the next three
months of COBIT I'm telling you it can
change your life
thank you Gary you will be blown away
Robbie by the random email so you will
get or D UPS I don't think it's out of I
don't think it's crazy that you're
crying on tea with Gary B on October 9th
because you signed a book deal about
your [ __ ] fantasy land book I really
believe this and be happy doing it it's
way more fun than bartender
yeah yeah that's thank you just do it
Robbie just [ __ ] do it please
I will what's your handle on Instagram I
have no Instagram right now I have
earned yeah I have no like public
Instagram right now yeah right you're
gonna do you didn't do all that you're
gonna sell Robbie listen to me please
don't let this moment pass please set up
those accounts don't be scared you know
start the process of getting comfortable
with not meeting affirmation start
getting comfortable with the person that
leaves a comment that says this is dorky
stop start getting comfortable the
person coming along that watches this
show but unfortunately is still hurt
inside themselves and comes and says I
show you and Gary you're not gonna make
it this story is stupid
start getting comfortable with that
start start letting that bead you start
letting that get you excited that's them
they're down there down not you excited
god I look like I get excited I get
excited what people say I'm [ __ ] or that
I'm gonna fall or do you suck or you're
overrated or I don't get why people like
him or he's bad I get excited that [ __ ]
beats the [ __ ] out of me charger they're
confused
they think they're tearing me down
they're [ __ ] feeding me you can't beat
something that's unbeatable that's true
it's very true Gary please use this okay
brother I really weirdly believe
something Goods gonna I like weird leave
like genuinely my bones and my bones are
right more often than not I think
something good is gonna happen man
please can you please promise you'll
deliver on this I really think you'll be
happy even if nothing crazy happens
you're gonna feel so good at the end of
these three months I will I believe I
promise I'll contact you if anything
happens then please
thank you all right thank you you're
welcome Robbie this was a real show yeah
this was like a real [ __ ] show yeah I
related with Robbie a lot you did yeah I
mean like just uh first just not knowing
how young he is at 25 like everyone
thinks they're sold and even I felt that
when I was 25 like oh crap like I got to
get my life together in five years here
whatever and people don't realize how
young they are like it's just it's
frustrating like hearing it all the time
from 20 year old I'm like you don't
realize how young you are like that's
why we do this every day
speaking of every day tomorrow please
take the URL that you're watching right
now if you're in if you're in Twitter or
Facebook or link then please share this
right now tell everybody to join
tomorrow 9 a.m. and please set up
Twitter with your review of today's show
please Gary be on Twitter also today's
wine Texas bonkers if your wine drinker
white XCOM some of you are slipping on
that and in sports cards make sure you
watch or listen to the last show and
there's a couple long-form videos of me
on youtube around it it's really fun it
could be really really good especially
be you're a gambler and sports gamble I
think you should shift your energy or
consider it I appreciate you I'll see
you tomorrow
peace